PROFESSOR: So we've seen
that partial orders are
a set of axioms that capture
the positive path relation
or the arbitrary path relation
in directed acyclic graphs,
or DAGs.
But there's still another way
to understand these axioms
that gives a kind
of representation
theorem for the kind
of mathematical objects
that are partial orders and that
every partial order looks like.
So let's look at that example.
I'm interested in the
proper subset relation.
A is a proper subset of
B, which, you remember,
means that B has everything
in it that A has and something
extra.
So in particular, since
B has something extra,
B is not a subset
of A, certainly not
a proper subset of A.
So let's look at
an example of that.
Here are seven
sets, and the arrows
indicate the proper
subset relation.
Or more precisely, the positive
path relation in this graph
represents the proper
subset relation
where edges are understood
to be pointing upwards.
So I've left out the arrowheads.
This is also known
as a Hasse diagram,
where the height
is an indication
of which way the arrows go.
So if arrows are
pointing up, this
is telling me that, for example,
this set of two elements,
1 and 5, because there's
a path up to the top set,
the top set has everything
that this lower set has.
Namely the top set has 1 and
5, and it's got extra stuff.
The set consisting of just 1
is a proper subset of 1 and 5
because the set has 1 in it,
but it has an extra thing, 5.
And also, there's a
path from 1 up to 1,
2, 5, 10 because 1, 2, 5, 10
has a 1 in it and extra stuff.
So that's what the
picture is illustrating,
the proper subset relation
on this particular collection
of seven sets.
Now, let's look at a
very similar example
of the proper divides
relation on some number.
So proper divides
means a properly
divides b if a divides b
and it's not equal to b.
And I'm interested in the
proper divides relation
on this set of seven numbers,
1, 2, 3, 5, 10, 15, and 20.
And now there's a path from 5 to
30 because 5 is a divisor of 30
and it's not equal to 30.
It's a proper divisor of 30.
And of course, the
point of this picture
is to show that the proper
divides relation on these seven
numbers has exactly the same
shape as the proper subset
relation on those seven sets.
So there's the seven sets and
their proper subset relation
shown by the picture followed
by the proper divides relation
on this set of seven numbers.
And the precise notion
or sense in which
these things have
the same shape--
obviously they can be drawn and
one superimposed on the other.
But abstractly what we care
about with partial orders
and digraphs in
general is when things
are isomorphic-- is
the technical name
for the same shape--
and isomorphic means
that all we care about
are the connections
between corresponding vertices.
Two graphs where the
vertices correspond in a way
that where there's a
connection between two vertices
there's also a connection
between the corresponding
vertices are isomorphic.
And the precise
definition of isomorphic
is that they're
isomorphic when there's
an edge-preserving matching
between their vertices.
Matching means bijection.
And the formal definition is G1
is isomorphic to G2 if and only
if there's a bijection from
V1, the vertices of G1,
to V2, the vertices of G2, with
the property that if there's
an edge between two vertices u
and v in the first graph, then
there's an edge between the
corresponding two vertices
f of u and f of v
in the second graph.
And that's an if and
only if relation.
There's an edge between f
of u and f of v if and only
if there's an edge between u
and v in the original graph.
And that's the
official definition
of isomorphism for digraphs.
And the theorem
that we illustrated
with that example of proper
divides and proper subset
is that, in fact, every
strict partial order
is isomorphic to some collection
of subsets partially ordered by
less than.
So this is a kind of a
representation theorem.
If you want to know what kinds
of things are partial orders,
the answer is that a
strict partial order
is something that looks
like a bunch of sets
under containment.
It's isomorphic to a bunch
of sets under containment.
And the proof, actually, of
this is quite straightforward.
What I'm going to do to find
an isomorphism is you give me
your arbitrary strict
partial order R,
and I'm going to map an
element a in the domain of R
to the set of all of
the elements that are,
quote, "below it," that is,
all of the elements that
are related to R.
So a is going to map
to the set of b's such
that bRa or b is equal to a.
And that is added for
a technical condition.
Remember, R restrict, so a
is not related to a under R.
But I want it to be
in the set that a maps
to, so I'm throwing that in.
Another way to say this
is that the mapping f of a
is equal to R
inverse of a union a.
And let's just illustrate
that by the example of,
how do you turn the divides
relation into the subset
relation?
Well, the smallest element
in the proper divides example
was the number 1, and
I'm going to map it
to the set consisting
of 1, which
is all of the elements that
properly divide 1 along with 1.
And then I'm going
to map the number
3 to all of the elements that
properly divide 3 along with 3,
and that is 1 and 3.
5 maps to 1 and 5.
2 maps to 1 and 2.
And at the next level,
I'm going to map 15
to all of the
numbers that properly
divide 15 along with 15.
So 1, 3, 5, and 15 are
what the number 15 maps to.
That's a set.
Likewise, 10 maps to 1,
2, 5, 15, and 30 maps
to all of the numbers that are
below it, including itself.
And this is the general
illustration of the way
that you take an arbitrary
strict partial order and map
elements into sets, which are
basically their inverse images
under the relation.
And the sets have exactly
the same structure
under proper containment
as the relation.
So this is, again, a
representation theorem
that tells us that if we want
to understand partial orders,
they are doing nothing more
than talking about relations
with the same structure as
the proper subset relation
on some collection of sets.